I think a lot of companies are seeing
the importance and the value of Hosting
Retreats now especially after two years
of covid where there is a growing sense
of isolation
[Music]
my name is Sean Hoff I'm the managing
partner of moniker a lot of companies
that either gave up their office during
covid and moved to a fully remote model
or a hybrid model have reached out to us
and asked we could help them plan their
first Retreat you see their names on
slack or they pop up in your email all
the time but being able to put that face
to the name and allowing you to actually
develop that relationship we've just
anecdotally seen people write in after
on the post-trip surveys talking about
how reinvigorated and re-energized they
feel after the retreat having been able
to kind of reconnect with their
colleagues the tools and our ability to
work remotely has made it possible to
build what we've built but the human
connection piece of it is vital to what
we do and the Retreats just amplify that
a million fold every time we do them for
us these Retreats have become probably
our number one retention tool because
people grow closer together they
understand each other more they end up
working better together because of it
and the excitement level goes through
the roof and it has this halo effect
that lasts for the rest of the year if
we do them right my advice is is they're
done right and you go in with the right
attitude and you actually really care
about them the return is absolutely
no-brainer
[Music]
somebody will find us either through a
referral and get connected to us
directly or they just find us on the
internet and we'll have a conversation
talking a little bit about what it is
that they're looking to do whether it be
a short celebration type Retreat or if
it's going to be like a few days abroad
where there's a mix of work and some fun
from there we would put together a
proposal sharing three to five
destinations talking about where we
think would be an appropriate place to
take the group based on budget where
people are coming from what they're
trying to accomplish from there once we
lock it in we start to put together the
day by day itinerary and the
corresponding budget and then as we get
closer to the date we're working on the
little things like what are we going to
see what are we going to taste what are
we going to feel
I got a call from China or either
clients what kind of needs you have tell
me the age what kind of expectations if
it's in Florence we think about
something if it's in Rome we think about
something else step by step we go
through the program even though if it's
a simple day you know we need really
really a lot of planning and schedule
times let's say maybe for this I would
need this Castle so I called the castle
and I explain the things that I need and
then I called the cooking classes and I
called the mama and say listen we need
to do this and do this and it has to be
done for this reason
if you've got a group that's coming from
all over the globe what we recommend is
a fortnight length we just find that
that first night people can be a little
bit jet lagged keep it simple make sure
everybody feels warmly welcomed and then
at dinner but nothing too serious in the
next few days it gives you enough time
to really allocate a fair amount of the
agenda towards mixing in the work and
then also having enough free time or
optional activity sprinkled in typically
the best model is to do the work in the
morning so you you have your breakfast
and then everybody kind of gathers in
the meeting space you might have a
breakout session where you just get
together with your smaller team or
Department ideally you're trying to end
the day by about two o'clock it gives
your people enough time to either relax
have some leisure time to go explore the
property or potentially go off site or
you can host full team team building or
an optional activity where the group can
get together and actually just you know
have some fun together we work together
on the theme we'll lean into that and
then create games and contests and other
events along the way to tie into that
and really make it feel like a cohesive
over-the-top experience biggest thing is
to deliver Happiness joy and emotion so
no matter what the activity it is it can
be a simple wine tasting it can be a
cooking class or maybe a sort of game
with the cars like we did with Sean
[Music]
there's this company Plex that we've
worked with for many years one of my
favorite activities that we planned we
took them to Tuscany back in 2016. they
were looking for for something to get
people out exploring the region we
staged essentially The Italian Job a
bank heist so we told the group to come
meet us in the parking lot and sure
enough their version of like the special
police comes tearing down the driveway
Sirens blazing and he pulls through a
stop in front of them and he gets out
and everybody's looking at each other
having no idea what's going on and he
basically starts to explain that there's
been a robbery in the nearby town of
Monte San Savino and their police force
is small and they heard that this group
was in town and hopefully they could
help enlist them to solve this crime
they drive Monte San Savino and we had
an actor with his wrists bound and tape
over his mouth sitting in front of this
Bank these attendees walk up they take
the tape off and he says yes yes I was
just robbed there were three people who
just left this bank and as they were
leaving this piece of paper dropped out
of their back pocket and it just kind of
evolved into this really fun circuit
with a whole bunch of diversions and
side quests was just an awesome way to
explore the destination that we were in
but at the same time bring the team
together
foreign
[Music]
ly think that the industry around
Retreats and off sites is just at the
cusp of exploding over the course of the
last two years obviously with kovid tons
of companies moved into a remote
structure or at least a hybrid structure
it's allowed companies to hire the best
talent wherever they are being a part or
being isolated and working from home for
the last two years has really reinforced
this idea that there just is something
intangible about getting together in
person which you just can't replace by
Zoom calls or Zoom games and and
meetings on slack what we'll see at
least for the next few years is
companies probably will try to keep them
close to home as they navigate their
first Retreats but over the course of
the next few years I do think that we'll
start to see a trend of companies going
further abroad and not going to the
usual places Europe has always been a
very popular destination with our
clients but what we're excited about is
companies are starting to ask us a
little bit more about off the beaten
path destinations
foreign
[Music]